PEGI three the scrub is a maneuver aimed  at minimizing the amount of time spent  in the air allowing the rider to start  accelerating again as soon as possible  to perform a scrub move both sticks in  the direction you would like to scrub  towards causing a sharp sideways  movement of rider and fight the timing  of the maneuver is essential in pulling  off an effective scrub anticipate the  movement too much and you risk falling  or landing outside the track leave it  too late and you'll just perform a  single whip the ideal moment is just  before the actual jump when the wheels  of the bike are about to lose touch with  the ground the better your timing of the  scrub the more linear your trajectory  will be mastering the scrub can make a  significant difference on the track but  obviously not all jumps can be taken on  with this approach you'll have to use  your riding experience to judge where  and when scrubbing will be to your  advantage  you